we didn't fail we didn't play
the buccaneers did but we're the ones
that get it
that's fine i understand but i can't
wait to give it to the saints the next
time they
they lose to the falcons when they
shouldn't yeah i know well it's the
psyche of an nfl football player
i don't understand the players tweeting
at the show
and doing all that for one like you
weren't watching the pregame show you
were getting ready for a game so you
don't really know we picked them okay
i mean you just found out afterwards and
i understand
players are gonna use motivation
whatever but this is not a motivational
tactic
and i am i'm i'm with you i'm just i'm
sick of it
and it's like it's gotta i gotta i
thought about last night hey
you know a few weeks ago the denver
broncos did it to me with the new
england patriots i
all day yesterday all i thought about
was i should send a tweet out to denver
as matt ryan's going up the field for
the seventh time today
but i didn't but either way how dare we
say the bucks were gonna win i mean the
saints they've gone to overtime with the
bears and tried their best to lose it
they weren't that impressive against the
carolina panthers the week before that
they went to overtime against the
chargers
i mean the lions it went down to the the
end of that football game
so i mean what what in new orleans just
makes you think we were going to sit
there and just go
no i mean the saints are unbelievable
there's no way they're going to lose
this game
so you know yeah we picked the bucks but
sorry
and you proved this wrong and you kicked
some butt and now we're going to discuss
how you kick some butt and it was windy
and drew brees entered the game with a
shoulder injury yeah
all the signs pointed to the buccaneers
winning which is why
everybody picked the buccaneers to win
everybody who picks games picked the
buccaneers to win
and maybe at some level that dynamic
that they begin to sense
in the locker room because even though
they didn't see our show
because they were on the field getting
ready for kickoff they saw all the other
shows they're right
they knew and sean payton is good enough
of a coach that he can take that
and use that as the last little thing to
get his guys riled up
and so and here's the thing if
if we anticipate that see we we're in a
no-win
position i'm not complaining i'm just
fascinated by it
if you factor into your analysis well
if everyone picks the bucks then the
saints are going to win then people
start picking the saints it takes that
factor away to the extent that that
factor
ends up being a motivator chris no i i
know
it does but i think you know what you
said earlier in the day
sean payton those type of things they
watch everything there in new orleans
we both know that okay you know they're
they are the type of team that
all you're saying about this oh yeah
yeah we don't pay attention to the media
bullcrap they know it
you know we've gotten text messages and
things like that throughout our careers
and things like that so
they're paying attention and i'm sure
they were writing notes and
ultimately i mean what we saw
was we saw one team who was like wait
we're the kings in the nfc south who the
hell do you think you
are you know you're not as good as you
think you are
and we're we're battle tested a football
team that's been together for years and
years
and knows what it's like to overcome a
little adversity and play in these big
games
and then you saw another team who was
like hey we got antonio brown it's tampa
it's sunday night football
it's an awesome show we haven't been on
here in like 13 years
we're gonna put a show on for you
everybody out there and the saints are
like boom boom boom
oh yeah how's that show oh okay yeah
let's keep going boom boom boom
and the game was over i mean that's
really how it went it was unbelievable
well it happened so fast too that the
buccaneers never really had a chance to
catch their breath
it was 28 nothing before you settle in
with your first bowl of popcorn in your
first bottle of beer
and i kept thinking maybe there's a way
that
tom brady and company can turn this
around but this is where you got to
credit the saints
you never get yourself into a spot where
you're in a falcons
type of a jam if you never
let the opponent breathe right and
and that's where i got to give the
saints sean payton dennis allen a ton of
credit
they never let the buccaneers breathe
they never let them think there was an
opening
that there was an opportunity to get
back into the game no i think it's uh
a really good point by you because
that's why i i think that's
where to start is the saints defense
what they did
you know this is a top 10 defense in
football this is where they've been
frustrating this year
they have moments in every game where
they're just dominant and nobody can do
anything
but then they let up a big bomb or two
big bombs and a big run and you're just
like what how did that team just
dominate the last four series
and then do that but last night it all
came together it really did
and you know i think with with brady and
company there too
you know there was never an
establishment of physicality on the
offensive side of the ball
at any point and the saints came out on
defense and really
like got up in the face of of the tampa
bay buccaneers
i i don't know if that surprise tampa or
what but i mean lots of people at the
line of scrimmage
dbs in the face of mike evans and
everybody else like we're not scared of
you here we are
we're gonna make you have to throw in a
man coverage of the tight windows do all
that
and then tampa came out almost like
i don't know maybe i'm off beat here
mike but i mean
it's like they came out just going we're
gonna get in the shotgun and we're gonna
throw on you and you can't stop us we
got brown and evans and godman and gronk
and that's just the way it's gonna be
and then and and it was just a totally
different approach from the other side
of the ball and there you see it's only
four rushes really from the running
backs and to me that was the
the biggest out or thing that popped to
me in the game is one team
really got in the face of the other and
even with drew brees on the offensive
side of the ball i know it wasn't about
physicality and running
but it was tempo it was quick passes it
was crisp
they had a game plan as far as how they
wanted to attack that way
and the bucks just couldn't get anything
going on offense couldn't get out of
their own end zone
to even create field position i mean
that was how bad it was
yeah and look
it yeah it wasn't supposed to be that
way and who the hell knows
why it happened or how it happened the
buccaneers played them much
better in week one when tom brady was
just getting his feet wet as a member of
the tampa bay buccaneers so look i i
think that
if you would have forced any saints fan
to put money on that game to put their
deed on that game yeah
to put anything of value on that game
last night
they would have taken the buccaneers i
saw some people who covered the saints
regretting that they picked the
buccaneers to win
everything was pointing in that
direction and
it was just one of those nights and i
think that's what you have to do if
you're the buccaneers
you just have to look at it and say it
was one of those nights
and we need to forget about it the same
way we would forget about a blowout
victory
right here's a little bruce arians and
tom brady talking about
last night's beat down by the saints
it was shocking to know just watch this
practice where we practiced all week the
confidence we had coming in
yeah we have to go back and look in the
mirror coaches players everybody just
from yesterday to today and you know
another where we go three and out
and then give up a touchdown um
second half i thought we we got to turn
over and we don't score a touchdown i
thought that
kind of was end of it right then and
there and uh but
i mean i've given new orleans credit
they kicked our ass in every phase
when things don't go your way you know
sometimes they just they keep going that
way and
you got to figure out how to stop it and
then turn it around and we had our
opportunities and we just didn't do it
so we got to learn from it and
um you know hopefully we can learn from
it and be better next week
so it's not about predicting the future
you know i'm not here to say this is
what we're going to do based on
losing the game we're we're going to get
back to work and try to do a lot better
next week
yeah and they've got the carolina
panthers up next and the
panthers look pretty damn good on sunday
against the kansas city chiefs and it's
not going to be easy for the bucks to
rest away you start looking down the
line they have the chiefs coming
up they've got the rams they've got a
vikings team that's won a couple in a
row they still play the falcons twice
and the falcons are getting hot
so the buccaneers have to forget about
this
but they also have to figure out what
went wrong they have to prevent it from
happening again i see you down there
bingo square
look it's relevant to look at the
schedule everybody's looking ahead at
the schedule is
everybody getting a bingo sign no
networks of nbc when they talk about the
schedule
shut up rico did it last night and i
wanted bingo to i wanted to see bingo on
the screen but anyway it's not going to
be any easier for the buccaneers and
it's amazing how quickly
one day how one how one
90-minute slice of a day
changes your entire perception of two
teams chris
well yeah yes it does but i mean this is
where i think we got to keep it a little
bit into the big picture here
just with the tampa bay buccaneers you
know
this is where i'm oh it's a little
concerning for as far as the way the
loss went last night
and how physically dominant the saints
were and how good drew brees and the
offense
moved the ball in the tampa bay
buccaneers defense it's the second week
in a row
we've seen the buccaneers lose the
physical battle that's where it's like a
little concerning to me
the giants pushed the buccaneers around
two weeks ago that was one of the
you know the things that i looked at the
bucks to go
they got a standard here they win the
battle up front against just about
anybody
but on defense they're showing that vida
veya
him being hurt is a big deal their pass
rush
their run defense certainly not as good
and
you know i last week of course with the
giants and everything they did and
pressure and brady and all that that's
where it's a little bit
like okay tampa you know what what's
what's the deal here
really and i i am interested to see like
this is this is going to be interesting
to see because it's a young team as far
as
how close they are together how long
they played together here we got a
little adversity
you know i know they got brady and
company but they haven't gone through
anything like this it's gonna be
interesting to see how they bounce back
and everything
you know there's an alternate universe
where jason pierre-paul
manages to catch a pass that was thrown
right to him by drew brees when it was
scoreless
and takes off the other way and brees
can't catch him
and it's seven nothing buccaneers and
the game plays out from there
and it just shows you how and it usually
is two or three of those per game where
it can go either way
but that one right out of the gates who
knows maybe the final score would have
been
3810 instead of 38.3 but
but when you have an opportunity like
that and it just doesn't work out
and the the the avalanche begins
against you it it you just wonder
chris if if it would have been any
different if pierre paul can hang on to
that footage well
listen i mean sure yeah that'll dicta
that'll change the
the flow of the game certainly i mean
yeah you know you're putting a pressure
on the team right off the bat now they
get the ball back
and you know the defense has the
momentum and everything like that but
you know regardless that didn't happen
and the buccaneers offense was incapable
of doing anything
at no point did they try to establish
the line of scrimmage with the run game
they came out it's like they read their
press
clippings like like they oh we're not
you can't match up with us across the
board
and new orleans obviously had a really
good feel
for where tampa wanted to throw the ball
in certain formations
tampa has been at their best when
they've been able to run the ball and
run play-action pass
not when they come out running shotgun
and doing what you saw last night
and you know you saw two offensive line
get pushed around for the second week in
a row as far as protecting brady had
people around him there but
the fact that they couldn't even get out
of their
own way i think is just as concerning as
anything
that they couldn't move the ball to even
flip the field position
they made the game easy for drew brees
and company there was just never any
life or spark or fight from tampa bay
that really ever made you think they
could win the football game even when
jared cook fumbled on the two yard line
you were like well let's see
maybe tampa can get a little momentum do
something here nope one two three four
you're out punt the ball up new orleans
goes down scores
and and uh that's where i was surprised
mike just
the they out coached them tampa who's
been
physical and in your face type of
football team all year too i don't know
if michael thomas being back but they
played zone coverage
and seem to be like whoa we're scared of
you guys and i think in a lot of ways
that plays into the hands of drew brees
because it's zone coverage and then all
of a sudden
sean's like hey drew go to the short
passes go to the short passes here we go
and and it's ding dong doom doom doom
and all of a sudden he's surgical and
they're unstoppable and drew got in a
nice rhythm last night and played really
well
you know i don't know that we've seen it
enough for it to be a trend
no but but it's it's coming
tom brady's had three prime time games
this year with the american ears and
they have not been good in any of them i
don't know if it's just tom's getting a
little older and by nighttime he's tired
but
they lose to the bears they barely beat
the giants last
monday night right and then last night's
debacle
brady three interceptions a 40.4 passer
rating
drew brees four touchdown passes no
picks and breezes now
five and two all time against tom brady
and
after the game when michelle tafoya was
interviewing
troop breeze emmanuel sanders came over
and was yelling the real goat
here's the real goat and look
i know brady's got the rings but
drew brees has the numbers he
caught and passed tom brady last night
for the all-time passing touchdown
record and he's five and two
head-to-head against tom brady and that
chris has got to drive
brady insane well definitely i mean i
don't think there's any doubt
but you know drew brees the saints
whatever it is it's just
they rise to the occasion they're a good
football team it's a really damn good
coach
sean payton drew brees there's there's
you know there's so much to respect
about them
and the way they've run their
organization how tough they are
you know the last few years you know the
way we've always talked about these
seasons have
ended and here they are again six and
two
rounding into what we went into in the
weekend going
the saints are good but i'm not sure how
good i mean we've talked about how they
have the potential to be one of the more
complete teams
but we hadn't really seen that game this
year
and this was the first one where we went
damn
this is the saints team we've seen the
last two years who just
have moments of just steamrolling other
teams and running them over
so you know maybe that's what they
needed just a little shot in the arm to
go wait you know help
tampa you think you're hot crap okay
well we're coming into town here and
we'll see what you got
and uh i'd say watch out for the saints
now i mean the way that looked and that
type of win that can really jumpstart
you get you confident and get everything
going and let's go ahead and get the
bingo
call early on this one because the 49ers
are up next and that's not nearly
the level of competition it was a year
ago but i would not write off the 49ers
in any set of circumstances they play
the falcons twice in three weeks
and the falcons are not going to go easy
on the saints the falcons hate the
saints and the saints hate the falcons
but
still the falcons aren't the juggernaut
they once were even though they won
three out of four
the broncos are in there the eagles
chiefs vikings and panthers left for the
saints a lot of winnable games more
winnable games
for the saints than for the buccaneers
and the saints now have a one game lead
in the loss column
over the bucks and they've got that
critical
head-to-head sweep which means the
buccaneers have to finish
a game ahead of the saints or the saints
win that division
and last night went a long way toward
showing the saints are in position to
win that division so if the bucks are
getting to the playoffs this year
they got to go the wild card route they
got to do it the hard way they got to go
on the road
and that that makes for a much tougher
path back to tampa for super bowl 55
chris
yeah well it definitely does it's a year
where
you really just want the number one seed
so you don't have to play three playoff
games before you go to the super bowl
that's really it is that's that's all
that's all that matters
i mean you wrote an article on pft this
week home field advantage means nothing
this year
i mean it means absolutely nothing it's
all about hey just be cool to get the
one seed
so you can have a week off who cares
you know who cares two through seven who
gives a damn this year really just get
in the tournament
oh great you know oh yeah you gotta go
play uh
the rams with ten people in the stadium
oh whoopty do i mean who cares where you
gotta go on the road whatever it is
it's all about that number one seed this
year and they're positioning themselves
especially with the way the seahawks
looked yesterday you know again to where
you go
all right here you go saints got it
going and this is where the saints are
dangerous because
now they got the lead last night sean
payton just lets it all
fly right now it's the taste of hill
plays are coming out everywhere
and that's only going to embolden them
because now he got to run those plays
and now what's next the plays that come
off them so now the next team that plays
the saints is going to look at taysom
hill and some of the things they did oh
this is what they did with michael
thomas
and now sean payton has a little chip to
go oh this is
this is called the screw you chip these
are the things you saw last week
and now we're gonna do a vice versa and
change it all around and this is this is
where
he can usually go on a run and start to
get hot as a play caller play designer
and we've seen this from the saints the
last two years kind of
slow starters and maybe this was it this
year maybe it took to halfway through
the year to wake up and now start to
dominate the league
and last night was the first time this
year we've seen taysom hill used like he
was
right playoff laws to the vikings where
he was the best player on the field
he had two passes last night which is
one more than he's had in any game this
year completed both for 48 yards
he was the team's leading rusher last
night with over 50.
he had a catch for 21 yards he didn't
score a touchdown but
he did everything except score a
touchdown and he had that
bull in a china shop mentality where you
just got to get out of his way once he
gets ahead of steam it's got a derrick
henry quality to it
where once he gets going you don't want
to get hit
by taysom hill so look the comparisons
are all over the place
last night there was a suggestion by
chris collinsworth that he's like tim
tebow i don't know whether that's a
compliment or an insult i think at a
certain level
it's an insult to compare him to tim
tebow he may run like tebow but he
doesn't pass like tebow he passes
accurately
but if we see more and more taysom hill
if that offense diversifies
it it almost just felt like without
michael thomas they were a whole they
were just trying to hold it together
until
thomas came back and they weren't sure
what to do and it was just like let's
just hold it together and win as many
games as we can
and then when thomas comes back we get
the offense we want i i think so in a
lot of ways the fact that they kind of
survived without michael thomas for so
long
i think it's really just gonna make them
better
you know i think all you got to do is
look at the stat sheet the last two
weeks
you know look at the bears game look at
this game how many people touched the
ball on the new orleans saints football
team
in the run game and the pass game it's
not just the two running backs
so many people have different carries in
a different week
and the ball is spread out through
everybody it doesn't matter who you
are but now they got michael thomas back
to where
oh it's a big situation we can go to him
and then
oh you're double teaming him well we've
had lots of practice without him and
we've found other ways to get the other
guys the ball too and that
that can in the end in the end game
really be a blessing for new orleans
that they had to kind of find
offense without michael thomas and kind
of diversify that way
uh so it's encouraging and we'll see
where the saints go but like you said
the schedule sets up
for them to kind of go on a run and
maybe separate themselves here
from the buccaneers to a degree and you
know really make a push for
for this number one seed but a very
impressive win dominant awesome job by
sean payton
offensive line protected breeze all
night long
defensive line whoop the crap out of the
bucks and they showed that they were the
kings of the south once again
12 different receivers caught passes
last night for the new orleans saints 12
of them and none of them had
more than one target that they didn't
catch
that that it was just you know if the
incompletions were spread around to each
guy one each
and uh it's incredible to see these
numbers just
lay out this cascade down i know with
all those different guys usually it's
impressive it's
if there's six or seven there were 12
last night
different receivers who caught passes
for the new orleans saints and
you know we talk about playoff
positioning tiebreakers
the saints are six and two the packers
are six and two
the packers were the big winners this
weekend because
the packers don't hold the tiebreaker
with the bucks
they do hold the tiebreaker with the
saints dating back to a sunday night
game where
i think i picked the packers to win yeah
and i think the packers beat the saints
and i don't think the saints
twitter account had anything to say
about it then gee i wonder why
but but now they got to worry about the
packers yeah
apples to apples they finish with the
same record as the packers
the packers get the one seed and the
saints have to play out
three games to get to the super bowl
yeah that it's going to be interesting
to watch there and the packers are one
of those teams again i mean i know they
look good the other night against that
49ers football team
who was decimated all-time decimated as
we said
but they're a team we've looked at and
said there are some flaws on their
football team
to where them getting the number one
seed and having to play one last game
just shakes it out to where yup there's
one less team that they have to deal
with that has a flaw or anything like
that
so uh that that will come or prove to
probably be a big game
uh but there's so much football left to
be played the packers still got to play
the bears twice i know they got the
tennessee titans on the schedule
uh so we'll see where this goes but you
know
let's see if the saints can really
capitalize on this and and do
what we think they might be capable of
doing here which is kind of round
themselves into the best most complete
team in the nfc we knew they had the
potential
we hadn't seen that yet defense has
always had a few moments
offenses had a few moments and that's
why we picked the bucks last night
i mean drew brees tried to throw
interceptions to lose the game last week
against the bears
nobody makes the bears can't make big
plays on offense against anybody
and they were making big plays against
the saints so those are the reasons we
were concerned
and why we picked the bucks but they
fixed those good for them and
i'm excited to see what they do with
this win
the tampa bay buccaneers debuted antonio
brown last night
i was told before the game that the
target for his total snaps on offense
was somewhere between 29
25 he ended up with 39
snaps 78 participation in the team's
offense
three catches for 31 yards on five
targets
there was one where he kind of quit on
the route accidentally and yeah right
off
right but he did hey one of his catches
was impressive because it was a laser
from brady and he caught the back of the
ball and i know those gloves help
but they don't help to the point where
you're going to
snatch a laser out of the air and that's
what he did so he showed flashes
it just look when a game like that goes
sideways no one's going to stand out for
the buck
though that's right you're right it's
hard to get into rhythm as an offense
you know their game plan was taken away
they had to play a game that they did
not want to play
but i'm still amazed with how he looked
definitely
you know and you talked about hey that's
that's a new guy in a new offense
he got him he wasn't sure of the read
you know sometimes with those type of
plays it's like
hey if the db's close to you and press
on you you run the go route if he's
playing off of you a little
we want you to stop and hook it up and
it kind of got an in-between look
and that's you know again that's part of
when you talk about chemistry between a
quarterback and
receiver nuances of an offense they'll
learn
they'll figure that out certainly but
man for a guy who hasn't played in
forever
uh he still looked pretty damn good to
me i mean still can run
was open deep one time with brady kind
of under throw him they had the fourth
down where brady tried to throw to gronk
down the middle remember and just missed
it on the long fourth
the fourth and short throw man antonio
brown was wide open next to him
um so good signs and we'll see if they
can learn how to kind of infuse him in
the offense more and more
they got their work cut out for them
because now they have to make up a game
in the standings
and actually two games in the standings
the rest of the way because they have to
get ahead of the saints if they want to
win that division that relies on the
saints
losing some games they did not look like
a team that was ready to lose any games
last night
dancing in the locker room sean payton
into it we have the video
of peyton oh yeah the players oh there
he is
that's not bad okay that was all right
he doesn't have as much rhythm as davos
sweeney and clemson but he's pretty good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports